un échange et négociations ce sont les
deux est ce que nous voulons absolument
sortir de cette situation s'est
compliquée c'est extrêmement difficile
puisqu'il ya plusieurs sujets sur la
table et un sujet crucial
qui est la question sanitaire
à côté de ça vous avez là toutes les
questions qui sont liées à la cherté de
la vie à l'énergie aux plus du gaz à la
question du développement
la question de la reconstruction des
hôpitaux et puis après son déjeuner ce
d'une manière mais ce point central
était extrêmement important il fallait
l'évoqué présence du ministre parce
qu'il n'est de responsabilité au niveau
de l'état et donc
personnellement j'ai
donner mes conditions
si c'est pour revenir sur ce qu'on a
déjà décidé samedi dernier et vendredi
dernier c'est à dire pour met tout sur
la table et qu'on s'y est compris la
question de l'obligation vaccinale et on
a mis tout ce matin le théâtre puisse
trouver des pistes et des solutions et
souton répondre à un principe un double
principe de réalité la réalité sociale
nombre de personnes vaccinées en
martinique dans les institutions
hospitalières c'est une minorité et puis
aussi seconde on peut appeler la réalité
du besoin de continuité des soins et ces
deux éléments la faune que le ministre a
accepté
bien sûr que les propositions qui seront
faites les analyses qui sont faites au
sein des ateliers ils accepteront débat
est perçue il faudra tout pour répondre
à cette nouvelle réalité se jouera pas
comment le 31 décembre l'emploi
appliquer le pass vaccinales atténuées
mais l'obligation vaccinale tels que
c'est